[Music]
a musical tribute by Beyonce began the
memorial service for Kobe Bryant and his
daughter Gianna the event was billed as
a celebration of life 20,000 people
packed the Staples Center an arena where
Bryant's play gave LA Lakers fans such
joy and where he helped his team win
five NBA championships basketball legend
Michael Jordan wept openly as he
recalled his relationship with the man
he considered like a little brother in a
game of basketball in life as a parent
Kobe left nothing in the tank
he left it all former teammate Shaquille
O'Neal spoke affectionately about a
friend and teammate with whom he had
sometimes feuded I'll take comfort in
the fact as we speak Kobe and GG are
holding hands walking to the nearest
basketball court Kobe was showing us
some lumumba rules today and gg soon
masses of Kobe or Heaven's MVP the cause
of the helicopter crash that killed Kobe
and Gianna Bryant and seven others is
still undetermined although
investigators are focusing on the bad
weather and poor visibility at the time
of the accident attorneys for the Bryant
family have filed a wrongful death suit
against the company that owned and
operated the aircraft tickets for the
service were sold for a modest price the
proceeds will be donated to the Mamba
and Mamba Sita Sports Foundation which
Bryant founded to help inspire and lift
up underprivileged kids through sports
among the many emotional tributes
perhaps the most moving moment came when
Vanessa Bryant talked quietly about her
beloved husband and daughter God knew
they couldn't be on this earth without
each other he had to bring them home to
heaven together
babe you take care of our chichi may
both rest in peace and have fun in
heaven until we meet again one day we
love you both and miss you forever and
always mommy
a final farewell to a man who was seen
by many as representing the soul of his
City and the heart of his sport Rob
Reynolds al-jazeera Los Angeles
[Music]